the parents of Akari Henderson say their
faith is what's been holding them up
ever since their son died this past July
in an attack outside a bar in Greece and
you know one of the pastors told us that
in order for him to talk to us we need
to be happy because he was always happy
you talk to him
yes daily tell me what does he say we
just you know is mostly you know I hear
him saying dad you looking at the game
dad
this team's playing dad this team well I
can hear it you can hear his voice I can
hear his voice every day every day we
ask that the criminals would be
convicted to the highest level Jill and
Phil Henderson appeared with their
lawyers in a recent video on the website
of a Greek newspaper why did you seek
out the press in Greece what were you
hoping to gain from that well me
personally I wanted to make sure that
they just knew that you know we're human
too we're concerned we're parents like
most of them are probably parents and we
just wanted to appeal to them as human
beings not necessarily one country or
another country but just as human beings
you wanted to put a face on the parents
of this child right all right correct
and if justice in your mind isn't served
how do you live with that I don't know I
don't even think about it
I think the justice will be served and
maybe because I just can't imagine it
not being we know that God has already
gone before us and laid the way so I
just I mean we're gonna have to accept
whatever God's outcome is so I'm not
relying on man
at this point Bakari was in Greece
working on a photo shoot to launch his
new clothing line
his parents say they're reaching out to
manufacturers to be able to finish what
he started you're moving forward yes we
are why was that important for you to
complete well for me because he lost his
life trying to do something that he
dreamed of doing so if it was that
important to him to travel over to
Greece to get these photos and
you know to live his dream I don't want
it to just stop there you're wearing as
hat yes this is from his line one of the
things he did before he went to Greece
and the name did he did he have the name
on the Hat yes yeah it was always about
Picard yes yeah because Phil kept saying
who's gonna want to wear that nobody
knows you you know he's like it's not
like you're like Kobe or something you
can't just have Hari he's like that it's
gonna be alright it's gonna be alright
just wait that's the office it's gonna
be on I got you sorry for CBS this
morning Michelle Miller in Tucson
Arizona